Bob will be calling tonight's Red Sox
Yankees game on MLB Network as well as
both games of a doubleheader in the
Bronx Saturday on YES Network filling in
for Michael K Bob good to have you back
how are you hi Dan how you doing I'm
doing okay does baseball want to get rid
of fighting I don't know if they want to
get rid of all fighting or all conflict
yeah more or less but what they really
want to get rid of is intentionally
throwing above anyone's shoulders and
there shouldn't be any disagreement
about that
no old-school code or anything like that
should apply absolutely unacceptable and
what happened a few nights ago didn't
start a few nights ago there's a long
history as you know between the Pirates
and the reds and the Reds have reason to
believe that this wasn't accidental that
it's purposeful that it's gone on for
awhile and that's what said David Bell
off this didn't happen in isolation and
maybe because this was so extreme and it
went viral and because the suspensions
are more than what you usually get
coming out of an isolated brawl
maybe this will get people's attention
because this idea let move somebody off
the plate yeah I guess hit somebody in
the fire or in the backside yeah I guess
it just get away yeah I guess and
sometimes guys get upset when they're
hit by a slow curveball and clearly
that's not a matter of intent but there
are situations where it's very clear
what's going on and it's only a matter
of happenstance that somebody doesn't
get seriously hurt and that's what said
David Bell and the Reds off yeah just
trying to figure this out and you know
we're of an age where we understand
where you pitch inside you you know hey
that inside part of the plate is as much
mine as it is yours I get all of those
things it's when you're throwing a
baseball and most of these guys thrown
at least 95 miles an hour and when you
start to go up higher on the ladder here
and you go headhunting I mean it it I
can't imagine this commissioner is
sitting there going hey it's part of the
game or an unwritten rule here and but I
don't know if you can put out these
suspensions and say all right that
defend these guys off who want to do
this we're really gonna make you pay I
don't I don't know how you send send the
message where you don't have somebody
really taking somebody's life into their
own hands well there could be a flat-out
unequivocal statement coming from the
Commissioner's Office you know there
there are lots of things that were the
way the game was always played that
don't exist anymore collisions at home
plate until very recently were part of
how the game was played and then common
sense prevailed and your point is is
correct it was always a terrible thing
to intentionally throw above the
shoulders but you didn't have so many
guys coming in there pumping high-octane
gas the way you do now so that increases
the danger the computerized strike zone
it's it's mislabeled with the Robo
strike zone I've had
Clayton Kershaw on the show he's not
four word for it Don Mattingly was on
the show yesterday he is for it where do
you stand on computerized strike zone
everything is so quantifiable now from
so many different angles that I guess
it's inevitable but when the human
element is completely removed look you
want it to correct
egregiously incorrect calls you don't
want something like what happened
doesn't like what happened to took to
the Cardinals and poor Don dink injure
in 1985 and might have turned a World
Series the umpires don't want that
nobody wants that but if everything is
quantified down to the last micro
millimeter it just appeals to me and
maybe this is just generational it just
feels to me as if some of the humanity
has been bled out of the game I would
like to see it I'd like to see it used
for the all-star game next year and just
ease it in let the players talk Mike
them up the umpire can be miked up as
well let let everybody in on the
experiment and let's just see how it
feels because part of me wants to see
what real strike zone is Bob because I
don't know I don't know anymore well
nobody knows exactly and when you see
the strike zone box or whatever they
call it on any given telecast that may
be helpful but I don't think it's
absolutely
definitive are you getting a full
three-dimensional look at it I'm not so
sure you are and then there's the
question of a guy's stance what does his
strike zone in his stance
you know people people alter their
stance by a little we're talking about a
half a half an inch of Correction you
think a guy's stance doesn't change more
than half an inch from pitch to [ __ ]
sometimes
did you ever want to be an umpire for a
day you know I I um fired a couple of
softball games like maybe 40 years ago
yeah and then with softball games there
were slow pitch softball games I did it
as a favor to a friend and it's like a
beer league and this guy is yelling at
me he's yelling he's yelling at me and
actually couldn't have been 40 years ago
had to be closer to thirty because then
at least in some quarters people knew
who I was and I'm wearing a baseball cap
and I come out there and blah blah and
now the guy is just reaming me out for a
couple of innings and then he walks off
the money does a double take he goes Oh
Bob Wow I'm sorry my thing is well you
know don't abuse the next civilian to be
behind the plate so that that disabused
me of any notion that I wanted to be an
umpire talk to Brent Musburger about it
though wasn't he an umpire in the
Pioneer League or something I think he
was yeah Lincoln Montana does that say
all right yeah yeah we're talking to Bob
Costas the hall-of-famer he will be
calling Red Sox Yankees that'll be on
MLB Network tonight and then he's in the
Bronx over the weekend doubleheader
filling in for Michael Kay this right
where are we with this rivalry I don't
think it's quite as intense as it has
been at various times you know in the
70s today is the 40th anniversary of the
death of Thurman Munson you think about
Thurman Munson tangling with the Red Sox
and Carlton Fisk and Greg Nettles in the
70s Bucky Dent's homerun the epic 78
race and then right around the the turn
of the century this time a rod and Jason
Varitek and Pedro Martinez and Don
Zimmer and coming back from down 300 and
2004 and Aaron Boone's Homer off
Wakefield the year before that I don't
think it's quite as intense now and last
year the Red Sox
away from the Yankee so it wasn't tooth
and nail to the end and this year the
same thing seems to be happening in
Reverse and then odd bit of scheduling
the last game they played during the
regular season
is September 9th the last five years
prior to this they always met the last
few games of the season which set up
some drama if the race was at all close
so I think this year a lot of that stuff
is working against it and I'm gonna
bring in two sports here baseball in
football and two positions pitcher and
running back because I don't know for
getting to the point where it might be
harder to define what a great albeit
Hall of Fame pitcher is and the same
with a running back because it feels
like the rules are changing a little bit
because of how we use pitchers and how
we use running backs which which one do
you think's a little bit harder to
define what makes a Hall of Fame pitcher
starting pitcher and a Hall of Fame
running back well I don't go with the
idea that you can just compare by
percentage somebody pitched 5 good
innings and so that's a great outing or
six good innings that's a great outing
it might be good but it's not great you
still value the Verlander's and the
Scherzer's who can go deep into a game
and I would assume that Hall of Fame
voters would take that into account
rather than just looking at okay here's
the ER a here's the whip but the guy
only went five or six innings on average
as opposed to the guy who went deep into
the game when it comes to football
obviously with so much emphasis on the
passing game and now with a 16-game
season is compared to historically way
back 112 and more recently 14 and maybe
they go to 18 what does a thousand-yard
season mean and how effective is a
running back as a receiver that's much
more of a deal and they used to throw
screen passes to Jim Brown who could do
everything but that wasn't the primary
idea that we're handing him the football
that's not as much the case now as it
used to be because it's so past heavy
we've talked about expanding the netting
we've talked to you know people about
this whether it's players whether it's
management whether it's you know stars
and then I keep hearing different things
as to why we don't have
netting for all ballparks and then the
Commissioner said look it's up to the
individual teams doesn't the
Commissioner have the power vested in
him to be able to say I want this
netting up and I want it up in the next
two weeks yeah under the broad heading
which Bud Selig was always invoking of
the best interests of the game yeah it
ought to go all the way down to the foul
pole or if you've got an odd
configuration like Fenway Park we got
the side wall jutting out then it goes
all the way to that point all the way to
the point where you could reasonably be
concerned that a line drive could
endanger somebody and I really just
think it's a no-brainer to do that
and we don't need to wait until there's
a fatality at the ballpark to get the
message select like wait a minute we'll
put a stop sign at this intersection
after there's a 12-car pileup well if
you can see it comin if you can see the
possibility of it let's stop it before
it happens yeah I just I don't buy into
all what the Commissioner is leaving it
up to the team's the Commissioner did I
guess invoke his power and say we're
gonna put the netting from the backstop
over to the dugouts
so he already did that so I understand
if you're buying premium tickets and you
think that this is going to somehow
infringe upon your viewing pattern your
habits enjoying the game I get that I
just think you'll get to the new normal
where you don't even notice that net and
the other part of that was I thought Bob
if you lowered that netting in batting
practice and maybe you have interaction
with the players you get a baseball all
of that game it game starts nets come up
and then that's it but you know people
think they're losing the intimacy of the
game and I said you won't lose that
after a while you won't even notice it
but you know it's falling on deaf ears
yeah I think you're right about that but
after a while people will get used to it
and this is entirely unscientific but I
haven't heard any great hue and cry from
people who are sitting up close but
peering through the netting maybe it's
slightly different or disorienting at
the beginning but I don't think we've
got an insurrection on our hands and
just as you mentioned that pitching up
above the shoulders is more dangerous
now because so many people are
coaching triple digits and velocity
there's another factor when it comes to
people in danger and that is you watch
any game or you're sitting in the
ballpark and all around you people are
on their cell phones they're distracted
you know so so that increases the danger
what's the coolest piece of memorabilia
you have the coolest piece of
memorabilia that I have sports or other
you know I know I have baseballs signed
by Babe Ruth not inscribed to me I was
not on this planet when baby took his
leave but I have a Babe Ruth on
inscribed baseball and then I have
baseball's inscribed to me from Joe
DiMaggio Willie Mays Hank Aaron and
Mickey Mantle that's cool yeah yeah what
about but you used to interview a lot of
musicians did you ever collect anything
from musicians that you interviewed you
know come to think of it knowing
Springsteen Paul Simon Smokey Robinson
Tom pan
Carole King and I never I never driven
Tom Petty Oh Glenn Frey Bob Seger did I
say paul mccartney who I guess I could
have gotten all of them I got none of
them would you rather interview who's
more forthcoming an athlete or musician
it's a generalization
I'd say the musician because if they sit
down to talk to you or me they're
prepared I guess to be forthcoming
they're not interviewed on a regular
basis as much as athletes are but then
there's always exceptions you know I've
always used this example some people are
really good in talking about their craft
they talk insightfully rather than in
generalities among baseball players Ted
Williams was the gold standard of that
he could explain hitting to you he and
Tony Gwynn could explain hitting to you
better than Stan Musial could explain
hitting to you even though he was most
of virtually as good a hitter Jerry
Seinfeld could deconstruct a joke or a
monologue just as well as Ted Williams
could deconstruct hitting Tom Seaver
could do the same thing with pitching so
I guess it varies from from person to
person and then you have someone like
Springsteen who has you know hears that
to kind of tell you what what
encompasses this or how it happened or
you know those kind of things where you
can also talk to another musician who is
you know like you know even Bob De Niro
I don't think he explains his craft I
don't think he cares - but then Tom
Hanks could probably sit down and say
all right this is what I'm thinking when
I'm doing Mister Rogers neighborhood
here what well now okay since you
mentioned the names you mentioned just
conjures up an image from a few years
ago I'm at the White House which is not
a regular thing to me when I'm I don't
just drop in unbidden but I'm at the
White House for the Presidential Medal
of Freedom ceremony
it's toward the end of Barack Obama's
second term and Vin Scully is receiving
the Presidential Medal of Freedom and he
and his wife Sandy were kind enough to
invite me and Jill to come to the
ceremony so where we're hanging around
before it begins and everywhere you look
Diana Ross Ellen DeGeneres Michael
Jordan Kareem abdul-jabbar Tom Hanks is
there Robert DeNiro is there and
Springsteen is receiving a Presidential
Medal of Freedom okay so now picture
this I'm talking to Hanks but my back is
to what's happening in the corner of the
room but hangs can see it over my
shoulder De Niro meanwhile true to your
characterization is just kind of
standing there mono syllabic we looking
at the floor so I'm chatting with Hanks
about I forget what and he says hey look
at that what do you suppose this
conversation is like and I turned around
and alone two guys in the corner Vin
Scully talking to Bruce Springsteen
so Hank says what do you think that
conversation is like and I venture a
guess you know Bruce I loved greetings
from Asbury Park but you really hit it
out of the park with darkness on the
edge of town that's good stuff there
imagine that Scully and Springsteen
great artists in their own right
that's good hey great to catch up with
you have fun this weekend and MLB
tonight Red Sox Yankees and then on the
S Network filling in for Michael K this
weekend good to talk Bob thank you for
joining us thanks man Bob Costas
hall-of-famer for more Dan Patrick show
tune in the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]